if instead you want to go for the
classic big game treat i have the
perfect place for you and it's all
thanks to
brooklyn's best
for the big game special we're offering
a large cheese pizza and any kind of
wing they want
for the big game you get a big pizza
like this
huge we're going to cut into eight
slices for you guys
and we don't mess around you're not
going to get no cheap pizza we'll use
grandi mozzarella
san marzano tomato you're going to get
the best pizza you ever had
don't mess around don't go to these guys
over here new york style come get new
york
we have cheese pizza pepperoni pizza
sausage pizza supreme pizza meat lovers
pizza
sicilian style grandma style stuffed
pizza
any kind of pizza you want we got it
right here well you should celebrate
with us because we're the original and
the only ones that are truly from new
york from brooklyn
and we do it the right way straight out
of the oven bam
does not flop no flapping
no flopping here right way is it the
boss is here
i'm making the pies i'm making the dough
i'm doing the sauce for my guys
there's no one else making it it's not
frozen it's made here fresh every single
day
we just won uh a trifecta in the best of
las vegas
we won gold for best family restaurant
best casual restaurant silver for pizza
silver for best italian
and bronze for the wings the wings are
bomb we're not even a wings place
but we just renovated we got some new
hot boxes here
we just added some gelato we added
another pizza oven because we're so busy
uh we added another
slice display over here all new
refrigeration
our ranges are new we added a salamander
a lot of a lot of new equipment uh our
dining room's a little bit smaller due
to covert but
it's working right now a lot of people
are staying up later now
uh the work schedules are changing we're
now staying open at 2 am
every thursday friday and saturday
nights you know come see me i'll be here
we'll be selling slices all night long
the the menu never changes
and then also we got a nice mural coming
up all your favorite uh
brooklyn characters from biggie smalls
jay-z
j-lo they're all beyond the wall come
see them celebrate with us by giving us
a call or sending it in
uh via online ordering
or just come in uh but try to order your
stuff ahead of time because we're gonna
be real busy so you can get that big
game special
for just 27.95 that's a large cheese
and any wing any style
[Music]
that's brooklyn's best pizza and pasta
to get the game day special
it's 27 95 for large cheese pizza
and 10 piece chicken wings so just call
702-786-0103 or visit brooklyn's best
pizza and pasta.com